they'll take it and you got to believe
it's gonna come at about five six
seconds what he actually starts it here
comes Langston Galloway they're clearing
out the whole right side for Derrick
Rose Derrick Rose against through
holiday and he's got some little
mid-range it's over Detroit Pistons win
it and got what they wanted at the end
of the game now they're saying we're
gonna look at the clock but I believe it
went through is the clock expired why
when a guy dribbles it that much that
deep sometimes you think well if I run a
double I really they really space the
floor well right they did a really good
job of spacing the floor Andre Drummond
started out that play in the far corner
right but you're at this point if you
run another one at him he's too late to
make a pass that's that's a heck of a
move yeah base against a very good
defender yeah see I think it's over
they're gonna be free 10 to the second
on that means as the pounds do have a
timeout so they could advance it all the
PALS can do now you can't catch and chew
it's got to be at the rib